[Music]
these are two of the most important
people shaping the future of artificial
intelligence Sam Alman the CEO of open
aai the startup behind chat GPT and
Satia Adela the CEO of Microsoft open
ai's biggest investor they spoke to the
economists editor and chief about what
the future of AI really looks
like Sam let's start with you what are
the most important capabilities that
chat GPT will develop in the next year
the world had like a twoe freak out with
gp4 right this changes everything AGI is
coming tomorrow there are no jobs by the
end of the year and now people are like
why is it so
slow
um and I love that I think that's a
great thing about the human spirit that
we always want more and better we've not
had this where there has been some
general purpose technology whose
diffusion happened instantaneously
everywhere in any place Healthcare and
education is most to the government span
you now have right the ability to give
every student and every citizen of the
of the globe a better health advis and a
better personalized tutor you know I
often think one interesting way to
measure this is what percent of tasks
can gb4 do let's say it's 10% can GPT 5
do 12% of human tasks or 15 or 20 but
the fact that so many people are able to
use it for productivity in their
workflow that's the power and I know
it's not as satisfying as saying here's
each thing it will do but it's that it
becomes a companion for knowledge work
it becomes a way to use a computer I
hear that and that's that's a absolutely
appropriate answer to my question but I
guess I'm trying to get at the sense of
whether this is incremental or whether
it's radical even in the next year I
believe that someday we will make
something that qualifies as an AGI by
whatever fuzzy definition you want the
world will have a twoe freakout and then
people will go on with their lives
samman just said the world will only
have a two we freakout when we get to
AGI that's quite a statement to make one
thing I say a lot is no one knows what
happens next and I can't see to the
other side of that event horizon with
any detail but it does seem like the
Deep human motivations will not go
anywhere this is when people start
getting alarmed that we have no idea
well I think that's just going to have
an intelligence that is more
intelligence than all of us and we have
no idea what happened no no like one
thing I love to do is go back and read
about the contemporaneous accounts of
technological revolutions at the time
and the expert predictions are just
always totally wrong and you need to
have some flexibility in your opinions
and look have a tight feedback loop with
how it's going with the world the amount
of focus on safety and regulation is
sort of very very high tell me what you
whether you think Regulators have got it
right or whether we're not doing enough
at this point you know if I look at what
the White House EO is or what the UK
safety Summit is what's happening in
Europe what's happening in Japan they
are going to have a say nation states
are absolutely going to have a say on
what is the regulation that controls any
technology development most importantly
what is ready for deployment or not and
so I feel like we will all be subject to
those Rags if you were ever in that room
and you thought to yourself this is
getting dangerous and this could
actually have consequences that I would
not want upon the world would you then
shout stop and would you stop there's no
like one big magic red button we have
that blows up the data center which I
think some people sort of assume exists
it's not this binary
gostop decision it is the many little
decisions along the way about allow this
don't allow this how to predict what the
the risks of the future are going to be
how to mitigate those set this new value
here um things like that thanks for
watching to watch the full interview
click the link and subscribe to The
Economist